[موسيقى]
اسعد الله مساءكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض التي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار ملفات السعوديه والخليج
وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
ابي نعامه حلف الناتو يعتبر ان تقديم
الصين مساعدات عسكريه لروسيا سيكون خطا
جسيما
عشيه محاكمته في منهات ترامب يؤكد انه
سيستعيد منصب الرئاسه في الانتخابات
المقبله
اللجنه الوزاريه في اوبك بلس تؤكد اهميه
الخفض الطوعي والاسعار تقفز بعد القرار
مصادر كويتيه تكشف عن اجتماع لمجلس
الوزراء اليوم والبرلمان يعقد غدا اولى
جلساته بعد قرار الدستوريه
في الرابعه نناقش ايضا
وزاره التجاره السعوديه تكشف عن تسجيل 65
الف سجل تجاري جديد خلال الربع الاول
الطيران الامن في السعوديه يواصل جولاته
اليوميه فوق الحرم المكي لمتابعه تنفيذ
الخطط
حياكم الله قال امينو
لا يشعر بالخوف من تهديدات روس النوويه
وسيواصل دعم اوكرانيا كما اشار الى ان
الناتو لم يلحظ اي تحركات في روسيا متعلقه
بتغيير وضعها النووي اضاف الامين العام ان
اعضاء الحلف ارسلوا لاوكرانيا مساعدات
عسكريه بقيمه 65 مليار دولار وقال ايضا ان
انضمام فنلندا للحلف غدا سيجعلها اكثر
امانا
هذا اسبوع تاريخي للنيتو غدا سنععلن
ترحيبنا بانضمام فنلندا لحلف الناتو العضو
رقم واحد وثلاثين ما سيجعل من فنلندا اكثر
امانا هو الحلف سيزداد قوه كذلك السويد
ستصبح اكثر امنا وكان هذا نتاج الدعوه
التي قدمها النيتو لانضمام فنلندا والسويد
للحلف العام الماضي وكانت اجراءات اتمامها
سريعه بالنسبه للحلف وكلنا نتفق على ضروره
انهاء اجراءات انضمام السويد بشكل سريع
اعلنا مكتب الرئيس الفنلندي ان البلاد
ستصبح عضو رسميا في حلف شمال الاطلسي غدا
الثلاثاء اضاف مكتب الرئيس الفنلندي ان
جميع دول حلف الناتو البالغ البالغ
اعدادها 30 دوله صادقت على بروتوكول
انضمام فنلندا للنيتو لتصبح العضو 31
واظهرت لقطات لاعلام الدول الاعضاء امام
مدخل مبنى الناتو تتوسطها ساريه في انتظار
رفع علم فنلندا بين دول الناتو
قال نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه الكسندر
غروشكو ان بلادها ستعزز من وجودها العسكري
على الحدود الغربيه والشماليه الغربيه ردا
على انضمام فنلندا للنيتو واوضح جروشكو ان
روسيا ستتخذ خطوات اضافيه لضمان امنها
العسكري عند نشر قوات ومعدات لاي عضو
للنيتو في فنلندا
من بروكسل ينضموا الينا مراسل العربيه نور
الدين الفريضي نور الدين مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض اولا ما هي اهميه
انقراض فنلندا الاهميه التاريخيه بالنسبه
لها الاهميه ايضا في تاريخ الحلف نفسه حلف
الناتو شمال الاطلس
ه في ان بالنسبه لحلف شمال الاطلسي
بالنسبه للمسؤولين في فنلندا يوم غد سيسجل
في تاريخ الدفاع والامن الغربي لان فنلندا
ستخرج نهائيا من مرحله من عقود من الحياد
لتنضم لحلف شمال الاطلسي وهي تقدم او تمثل
قيمه اضافيه بالنسبه للحلف تتمثل خاصه في
مساحتها الترابيه الكبيره جدا على حدود
روسيا لان
حلف الناتو يوم غد ستكون له حدود تمتد ب
1340 كيلومتر وهي الحدود التي تربط بين
فنلندا العضو بدا من يوم غد
وروسيا هيلسنك ستكون قريبه جدا من سام
بيتريس بولد اذا ما نشبت نزاعات مسلحه
كبيره بين حلف الناتو وروسيا هذا اضافه
الى ان هذه الدوله التي ست من حيادها
التقليدي ستوفر ايضا خبراتا لانها دوله
متقدمه من ناحيه صناعيه تستخدم
التكنولوجيا متوائمه حتى وان كان عدد
القوات الفنلنديه يبدو محدودا للغايات لان
المجندين او تحت الخدمه العسكريه لا يفوق
عددهم ثمانيه عشره الف ولكن البلاد بلد
مصنع وقادر في مرحله ما ان يرفع هذا العدد
الى عشرات الالاف خاصه في زمن الحرب حلف
الناتو قال يعني الانسان الامين العام ان
هذه الخطوه تخدم طبعا
ولكن ربما مساله تتعلق باسابيع واشهر
قليله لتنخرط هي ايضا ويصبح عدد
اعضاءها الى 32 ولكن الخطوه تبدو ما لا شك
في خطوه سريعه جدا كانت ناجمه مباشره عن
حرب اوكرانيا
قال ايضا بانهم سيناقشون في اجتماعهم
اجتماع الوزراء يوم غد مساله عدم
الاستقرار في جنوب دول حلف
النيتو وتحدث ايضا كذلك حتى عن مخاطر عدم
الاستقرار ربطها ايضا بتوسع النفوذ الروسي
والصيني وايران ايضا حتى كذلك ما الذي
اوجزه في هذه النقطه باختصار نور الدين
قال انه وزراء خارجيه سيبحثون مخاطر عدم
الاستقرار في جنوب الناتو وكذلك توسع نفوذ
روسيا وايران والصين اذا نحن نظرنا الى
منطقه الساحل الافريقي او جزءا من شمال
افريقيا بمعنى هناك هشاشه في الوضع
السياسي في تونس هناك هشاشه في الوضع
السياسي في ليبيا هناك تاجرات هجره يمكن
ان تستخدمها مجموعات فاجنر التي انتشرت في
مالي وانتشرت في جمهوريه بوركينا فاسو
التي تمكنت من طردي القوات الفرنسيه سواء
كان بالنسبه لماله لمالي سواء بالنسبه
هذه الاوضاع المتحركه يراها حلف شمل
الاطلس الان بمثابه الانذار للنسبه لهشاشه
امن جنوبي حلف في شمال حلف شمال الاطلسي
وفي ندوه نظمت يعني في الايام الماضيه قال
الامين العام او عرض حلف شمال الاطلسي على
دول افريقيا
هذه خطوه ربما ستاتي في مستقبل قريب سنرى
حلف شمال الاطلسي يمد يده لتوسيع التعاون
الامني مع دول لا يقتصر هذا التعاون على
شمال افريقيا وانما دول الساحل الافريقيه
ايضا هذا بالنظر خاصه لمواجهه في المنطقه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر مراسل العربيه نور الدين
الفريضه على كل هذه التفاصيل والمعلومات
قال مسؤولون امريكيون ان بالون التجسس
الصيني الذي حلق عبر الولايات المتحده في
فبراير الماضي تمكن من جمع معلومات
استخباراتيه لعده مواقع عسكريه امريكيه
حساسه على الرغم من جهود اداره بايدن
لمنعها واضاف المسؤولون الامريكيون ان
المعلومات التي جمعتها بكين كانت في
الغالب من الاشارات الالكترونيه مشيرين
الى ان الاشارات الالكترونيه يمكن
التقاطها من انظمه الاسلحه او اتصالات من
افراد القاعده بدلا من الصور كما اكد
المسؤولون ان الاداره الامريكيه تمكنت من
منع الصين جمع المزيد من المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه من خلال اخفاء قدره الدالون
على التقاط اشارتها الالكترونيه
اعلن الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
انه سيتحدث علنا من فلوريدا يوم الثلاثاء
المقبل وذلك بعد ساعات من مثوله امام
محكمه في منهات يتبلغ فيها رسميا بتهم
الموجهه اليه وقد ندد ترامبو حلفائه
بالاتهامات الزائفه والمخزيه معتبرين انها
من تدبير الديمقراطيين لتعطيل حملته
الرئاسيه واشككوا في نزاهه المدعي العام
في منهات الفنبراج
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وعشيره المحاكمه قالت ترامب ان انتخابات
عام 2020 مزوره ومسروقه مشددا على
استعادتها في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
عام 2024 مشيرا ايضا الى ان الهجمات التي
استهدفته لم يشهدها اي رئيس اخر في تاريخ
امريكا
لم يتعرض اي رئيس في تاريخ بلدنا لمثل هذه
الهجمات الشرسه والمثيره للاشمئزاز لكنهم
يهاجمونني فقط لانني اقاتل من اجلكم هذا
بسيط جدا لا يمكنهم شرائي ولا يمكنهم
التحكم به وهذا يخيفهم بشكل لا يصدق تمويل
حملتنا الرئاسيه دائما كان من قبل
الوطنيين من القاعده الشعبيه مثلكم
مساهمتكم اليوم ستظهر لليسار انه لا شيء
يمكن ان يدمر اعظم حركه سياسيه في التاريخ
قبل اداء افضل بعده ملايين وملايين
الاصوات في عام 2020 لكن الانتخابات تم
تزويرها وسرقتها
ولكن اليوم سنستعيد بلدنا في عام 2024
هذه الصور مباشره لطائرات الرئيس الامريكي
السابق
في احدى مطارات فلوريدا وكان مشاهدينا
ترامب قد اعلن من تلك الولايه التي يحكمها
منافسه
اعلن عن نيته العوده مساء الغد الى هناك
لالقاء خطاب امام مناصريه بعد ان يمثل
امام المحكمه في منهات حيث سيتبلغ فيها
رسميا كما جاء معنا في الخبر قبل قليل
بتهم الموجهه اليه سيتم ابلاغه رسميا
بتوجيه تهمه جنائيه في قضيه دفع اموال
لنجمه افلام اباحيه لشراء صمتها وذلك في
حدث غير مسبوق لرئيس امريكي سابق بعدها
سيتوجه طبعا كما قال الى فلوريدا لالقاء
خطاب امام مناصري يوم الثلاثاء
القادم وكما ذكرنا بعد ان يمتل امام
المحكمه في منهات الخميس كان
قد وجه الى ترامبي فيه الاتهام
اذن وترامب الذي يسعى بالطبع للعوده الى
البيت الابيض
وجه اليه الاتهام في قضيه مرتبطه بمبلغ
دفعه كما ذكرنا لممثله
اباحيه عام 2016 سيمثل اليوم امام المحكمه
في منهات ترامب كان قد ندده هو وحلفاؤه
بالاتهامات الزائفه
والمخزيه كما قال معتبرين انها من تدبير
الديمقراطيين لتعطيل حملته الرئاسيه 2004
قاده السعوديه خفضا طوعيا منسقا للانتاج
النفطي في عده دول داخل اوبك وخارجها
باجمال مليون و660 الف برميل يوميا بدءا
من مايو المقبل حتى نهايه العام الجاري
وستخفض كلا من السعوديه وروسيا انتاجهم من
النفط بواقع 500 الف برميل يوميا لكل
منهما فيما ستخفض الامارات الانتاج بعدد
144 الف برميل يوميا ثم الكويت بعدد 128
الف برميل كما اعلنت الجزائر ايضا عن خفض
طوعي بثمانيه واربعين الف برميل من النفط
يوميا تلك القرارات تسببت في ارتفاع اسعار
النفط لتسجل اكبر زياده يوميه منذ نحو عام
حيث قفز خام برنت بواقع خمسه وتسعه عشر في
المئه حتى لامس اعلى مستوى له في شهر عند
86 دولار ويعادل اجمالي تخفيضات اوبل بلس
نحو اربعه في المئه من الطلب العالمي
قاده السعوديه خفضا طوعيا منسقا للانتاج
النفطي من دول داخل اوبيك ومن خارجها
باجمالي مليون و660 الف برميل يوميا بدءا
من مايو المقبل وحتى نهايه العام الجاري
وفسرت الخطوه بانها اجراء احترازي لتحقيق
الاستقرار والتوازن في اسواق الخام وفي
التفاصيل ستخفض السعوديه انتاجها من النفط
ب 500 الف برميل يوميا فيما ستخفض
الامارات الانتاج ب 144 الف برميل يوميا
والكويت ب128 الف برميل يوميا كما اعلنت
الجزائر خفضا طوعيا بثمانيه واربعين الف
برميل يوميا كذلك اعلن العراق انه سيخفض
الانتاج ب 211,000 برميل يوميا فيما اعلنت
سلطنه عمان خفضا باربعين الف برميل يوميا
كذلك اعلنت كازاخستان عن خفض طوعي
بانتاجها
الف برميل يوميا فيما اعلنت الجابون عن
خفض بثمانيه الاف برميل يوميا وفي موسكو
اعلن نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسيه الكزند
نوفاك ان بلاده ستمدد خفضا طوعيا بانتاجها
من النفط بواقع 500 الف برميل يوميا حتى
نهايه العمل جاري من متوسط مستوى الانتاج
وفقا لتقييمات مصادر ثانويه لشهر فبراير
وسيضاف هذا الخفض الى الخفض الذي اعلنه
تحالف اوبيكلاس في اكتوبر 2022
والذي قضى بخفض بمليوني برميل يوميا حتى
نهايه العام الجاري هذا وكانت اسعار النفط
قد تراجعت الشهر الماضي الى ادنى مستوى
لها في 15 شهرا بالقرب من 70 دولار
للبرميل وفى ازمه المصارف الامريكيه وتدخل
الحكومه السويسريه لانقاذ كريدي سويس ما
يجري دينيه العربيه من الخبر ينضم الينا
خبير استراتيجيات الطاقه نايف مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
كيف يمكن ان نفهم هذه الخطوه بالخفض
الطوعي من دول اوبك ودول خارج ايضا اوبيك
هل هو خوف من انتقال عدوى الاسواق الماليه
المصرفيه وما حدث ايضا في الشهر الماضي ام
هي خطوه يمكن تبريرها بانها تستبق ربما
انخفاض الطلب المتوقع على النفط خلال
الايام القادمه
ويمكن ايضا بانها نظره غير متفائله
للاسواق تحت اي ظرف يمكن تصنيف هذه الخطوه
مساء الخير الحقيقه عده عوامل اجتمعت
لاتخاذ مثل هذا القرار في الخفض الكبير
اللي هو بوينت
سكس اول هذه الخطوات طبعا بالتاكيد هي
خطوه احترازيه خطوه استباقيه ولكن اذا
ننظر للي حصل مثلا في فبراير في فبراير
اعلنت روسيا
تخفيض طوعي بمعدل 500 الف برميل يوميا
وادخل حيز التنفيذ في شهر ثلاثه او شهر
مارس ولكنه لم يكن مؤثرا الحقيقه ولم يعني
يؤثر في استقرار
وتوازن الاسواق وبالتالي كان هناك حاجه
لاتخاذ خطوات
اكبر من قبل دول اوبك بلس وعلى راسها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وبقيه اهل
الدول الخوف او هاجس من انهيار اسعار
النفط تحت سعر السبعين دولار سيد نايف
والله هو كان الحقيقه انخفاض اسعار النفط
كان مقلق جدا لانه لم يعني لم يكن متصل
باساسيات الاسواق والحقيقه كان عده ضغوط
منها الضبابيه العاليه في الاسواق
العالميه منها الانهيارات التي تحدث في
البنوك والمصارف سواء الاوروبيه او
الامريكيه الان في قرار ايضا قرار الاداره
الامريكيه بعدم ملء المخزونات
الاستراتيجيه الحقيقه كان اشاره مقلقه
لانه
في استهداف لاسعار محدده يعني دار امريكيه
كانت تستهدف
بسعر 67 دولار
للبرميل حتى تملا مثل هذه المخزونات
الاستراتيجيه التي وصلت الى ادنى مستوى
لها منذ اربعين عام طيب مقدار خفض الانتاج
الطوعي بالنسبه لهذه الدول التي ذكرناها
في بدايه هذا الخبر هو مليون و6 60 الف
اذا اضفنا اليها ايضا
مجموع ما تم خفضه في اكتوبر الماضي نصبح
امام ثلاثه ملايين و166 الف برميل يوميا
هل يعتبر هذا اليوم في اسواق النفط
ولمستقبل اسواق الطاقه لاستقرارها
الاستقرار الاسعار هل يعتبر تدخل في الوقت
المناسب ام هو تدخل متاخر نوعا ما
اعتقد انه في الوقت المناسب الا احنا لو
تاخر القرار هذا في في
الاشهر القادمه اعتقد انه سيكون متاخر
لسبب لانه ليش ما هو متاخر لانه روسيا في
الشهر الماضي تقدمت بخفض طوعي مقداره 500
الف برميل يوميا وبالتالي كان على الدول
اوبك بلس ان تقيم الخطوه وترى هل هي كافيه
هل هي مؤثره هل ستجلب الاستقرار والتوازن
للاسواق وبالتالي درست مثل هذه الخطوه
الحقيقه ما كانت مؤثره وروسيا كانت عندها
مشكله الحقيقه في انخفاض الاستهلاك المحلي
وبعدين راحت في انتاج اعلى
للاسواق العالميه فما كان مؤثر الحقيقه
لخفض الروسي مع هذا الخفض الاسعار قفزت
بمقدار
5.19% يعني لامست تقريبا 86 دولار هل
نتوقع زياده في الاسعار خلال
الاشهر القادمه بدايه من ماي وهو الشهر
التي الذي سيبدا فيه الخف بشكل فعلي
انا ما اعتقد انه في ارتفاع كبير في
الاسعار راح اكثر من من اللي شهر طبعا
ممكن يكون في في ارتفاع طفيف اكثر من
المعدل لسبب لانه الاسواق الان حركه اسواق
النفط اصبحت ثقيله جدا ولا تعتمد على
الحساسيات التي كنا نشهدها في في السابق
ولانه هناك الحقيقه ضغوط فهناك عوامل دافع
دافعه وهناك عوامل تساعد على الضغط على
الاسواق فاحنا ما احنا في يعني في ظروف
مثاليه او مثل هذا الخط اتى حتى يقفز في
الاسعار هو عباره عن
توازن بين الظروف التي تدفع اسعار النفط
الى الاسفل وما بين
التخفيض الذي قد يعزز
ما اظن انه في ارتفاع هائل بسبب حركه
النفط الثقيله في الفتره الاخيره ممتاز
الظروف خفض الانتاج الطوعي هذا اللي يعلن
عنها امس قبل الاجتماع ب 24 ساعه هل تشابه
ذات الظروف التي خفض فيها الانتاج في
اكتوبر الماضي 2022
الحقيقه في عامل مشابه انا عامل اللي هو
عباره عن تهديدات
الركود ودخول في تباطؤ اقتصادي كان في
اكتوبر
واثبت صحته الحقيقه لما باتخاذ هذا القرار
لانه شاهدنا في الاشهر التي تلت اكتوبر
فعلا هناك في تباطؤ اقتصادي وفي هناك ظروف
واقتصاديه ما تدعو للنمو الان الوضع مختلف
تماما كمان لانه في في انهيارات في
المصارف وفي تخوف شديد من المستثمرين وفي
عدم وصول السيوله الى ايدي المستثمرين في
حتى في القطاعات النفطيه او حتى في اسواق
تداول النفط تشديد السياسات النقديه وصول
معدل الفائده الى هذا المستوى هذا حد من
وصول المستثمرين الى السيوله السهله خلينا
نقول مثل ما حصل في السابق وبالتالي
التداول عن النفط مثل ما ذكرت اصبح صعب
والحركه اسواق النفط اصبح ت اكثر ثقلا
الان شكرا جزيلا لك من الخبر انضم الينا
خبير استراتيجيات الطاقه نايف شكرا سيدنا
نايف
الرابعه مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعد قليل
الحج السعوديه تشدد على اهميه تعامل محلات
الصرافه المرخصه في مكه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديدة كده وزاره الحج
والعمره لزوار مكه القادمين من الخارج
التعامل مع محال للصرافه المرخصه للراغبين
في تبديل العملات وفي الوقت الذي تشهد فيه
كثافه عاليه من الزوار والمعتمرين خلال
شهر رمضان اوضحت الوزاره بانه بامكان
الحجاج والمعتمرين القادمين من خارج
المملكه اجراء معاملاتهم الماليه كافه
باستخدام بطاقات البنوك المعتمده ومحل
للصرافه المرخصه
من مكه المكرمه التحق بناء مراسل العربيه
اسامه القاسم اسامه مساء الخير مرحبا معك
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض وخلينا
نحكي على محلات الصرافه بما انك انت موجود
ايضا عند هذه المحلات لماذا شددت الوزاره
على اهميه التعامل مع هذه المحلات ما الذي
تخشاه في التعاملات الماليه
بجانب محل من محلات الصرافه المتواجده
بجانب الحرم المكي الشريف طبعا محلات
الصرافه المتواجده هنا تفوق العشره محلات
تقوم بتحويل العملات الخارجيه الى عمله
محليه ليستفيد منها الحجاج او المعتمرين
طبعا الزوار والمعتمرين اليوم عندما ياتون
من خارج السعوديه يتوجهون مباشره الى هذه
المناطق ويقومون بتحويل عملاتهم ما هي
البطائق اولا البطائق المعتمده التي
اعلنتها وزاره الحج والعمره هي الماستر
كارد وايضا الفيزا وايضا الامريكان ثلاث
بطائق وحدها فقط هي من معتمده هنا في
السعوديه وتحديدا اثناء العمره طبعا
المحلات تقوم بتحويل العملات على مدار
الساعه تحول اغلب العملات الى العمله
المحليه ليستفيد منها ايضا المعتمرون هنا
في مكه المكرمه طبعا تشهد المحلات هذه
الايام ازدحاما شديدا
بحجم او حجم زياد ايضا المعتمرين
المتواجدين الى الحرم المكي طبعا هذا
المحل الذي نقف فيه الان هو قريب جدا من
الساحات ننقل لكم الصوره ايضا الان من
الازدحام الشديد بعد اخذهم لاموالهم
وتحويلها طبعا سالت نايف لماذا الاهتمام
بتحويل العمله واهميه المعاملات الماليه
النظام البنك السعودي شدده بشكل كبير جدا
على اهميه معرفه العملات التي يتم تحويلها
لكي لا يتم استغلالهم وايضا الاحتيال
عليهم في هذه المرحله نشاهد الان ايضا عدد
من المعتمرين وزوار بيت الله الحرام
ياخذون الهدايا والاغراض بعد تحويل
اموالهم طبعا نايف عمليات كثيره جدا من
الاحتيال والاستغلال
العمره
المساله تتكرر مره اخرى وبالتالي كان
القرار الماليه يعني فيما يخص
الصرافه ايش اشكال نماذجها ايضا كيف يمكن
تجنب هذه العمليات عمليات الاحتيال
الماليه
نعم نايف اولا هي امام المعتمر امام
خيارين اولا ان تكون بطاقه احدى ثلاثه
البطائق التي ذكرناها مسبقا او ان يتم
تحويل عملته بشكل مباشر من محلات الصرافه
لماذا محلات الصرافه لانها اولا مراقبه
ومرخصه بعضهم يحولون من اماكن اخرى
وبالتالي تحصل هذه العمليات تكون لديهم
بطائق غير الثلاث البطائق المذكوره مسبقا
وبالتالي يعتقدون انه قد تم الاحتيال بهم
حيث انه لا يتم الشراء بها ايضا بعض الحجه
المعتمرين عندما ياتون الى هذه المناطق
لابد ان يحملوا هذه الثلاث بطائق او
يحملوا العمله المحليه بعد صرفها المحلات
المرخصه هي جوار الحرم المكي او في حدود
الحرم المكي هي تقريبا لا تتجاوز العشره
محلات معتمده كما اسبقت ايضا بعض المحلات
خارج حدود الحرم تقوم باستغلاله من حيث
رفع الاسعار وبالتالي هم يتوجهون مباشره
الى محلات الصرافه اعتقادا بان الخطا من
تحويل العمله وليس فقط من رفع الاسعار
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من مكه المكرمه مراسل
العربيه وسام القاسم على كل هذه المعلومات
التفاصيل الصوره التي نقلتها لنا من مكتب
المكرمه
اكد وكيل الرئيس العام في رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين للمشاريع والدراسات الهندسيه
المهندس محمد الورداني للعربيه ان نسبه
الانجاز في التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه
تجاوزت التسعين في المئه فيما بلغت نسبه
الانجاز لمشاريع توسعه المطاف 75% مشيرا
ان اعمال صيانه للمشاريع مستمره بالتنسيق
مع الجهات المعنيه مشروع التوسعه الشماليه
تجاوزت 90% نسبه الانجاز مشروع المطاف
تجاوز ال75% والعلم من الشواهد حقيقه اللي
نقدر ناكد عليها اليوم الان سطح المطاف
لاول مره يفتح بحله جديده بما يقارب 20
الف متر من الرخام التاسوس اليوناني
المقابل للحراره سطح التوسعه الشماليه
ايضا اول مره يتم فتحه بالكامل بمساعده
تجاوز 17 الف متر مربع يعني انجازات حقيقه
متواليه ومتتاليه
بعد تشغيل الحرم المكي بكامل الطاقه
الاستيعابيه بموسم عمره هذا العام تركزت
عمليات نقل المعتمرين والمصلين من والى
الحرم المكي على منظومه النقل العام بمكه
اتجهز ثلاثه الاف حافله تعمل على نقل اكثر
من مليون و 200 الف شخص يوميا الى المسجد
الحرام وذلك للتسهيل على الزوار وتخفيف
التكدس المروري في طرقات العاصمه
[موسيقى]
مع دخول شهر رمضان
تضاعفت عمليات التنقل من والى الحرم المكي
وداخلي مكه ما جعل القطاعات الامنيه
والخدميه تعمل على تنفيذ خطط منظومه النقل
العام حتى تضمن الانسيابيه والراحه
للمعتمرين والمصلين احنا الان مشاركين
تقريبا ب 2350 حافله وعلى استعداد انه
احنا نوفر وفق الخطه التشغيل المعتمده
3000 حافله لخدمه هذه المنظومه بشكل كامل
المعدل اليومي لنقل الركاب تقريبا من
مليون الى مليون و200 راكب تختلف من سبعه
وتفاوتها ما بين ايام
ونهايه الاسبوع خمس محطات نقل رئيسيه على
مداخل مكه التي تمكن المعتمرين والمصلين
من ايقاف مركباتهم واستخدام النقل العام
للوصول للحرم المكي
الى تسعه مواقف نقل داخليه تساهم في ايصال
المستفيدين من داخل مكه الى الحرم المواقف
الداخليه هي مواقف قريبه من الحرم
المده الزمنيه للنقل ما بيتجاوز العشر
دقائق من يوم ما يوقف سيارته الى ان يصعد
الحافله ومن ثم اتجاهه الى الحرم وابرزها
مواقف
ساحه كدانه هذه من ابرز المواقف بالاضافه
الى موقف الزاهر
وموقف في الجانب الاخر يعمل مشروع حافله
مكه على تقديم افضل وسيله للنقل العام عبر
اثني عشر مسارا تغطي الشوارع الرئيسيه
والفرعيه والشوارع الممتده بين الاحياء
ويلعب دورا هاما في تقليل اعداد السيارات
في شوارع وطرقات مكه في موسم العمره
من مكه المكرمه سلطان السلمي العربيه
منذ سنوات طويله اختار عبد العزيز
المحيمدي واصدقائه تناول وجبه الافطار
الرمضانيه في صحراء الغضب بمدينه عنيزه
حيث يفضل الكثير هذه العاده زميل عبد
الرحمن العصيمي زار مدينه عنيزه من
السلسله تقارير رمضان معهم نشاهد
[موسيقى]
عنيزه او كما يحلو لمحبيها تسميتها بباريس
نجد اجواء روحانيه وعادات يتوارثها
الاهالي جيلا بعد جيل لنتعرف على ابرز
ملامحها
عاده رمضانيه مستمره منذ سنوات بين عبد
العزيز المحيمدي واصدقائه تناول وجبه
الفطور في صحراء الغداء في عنيزه كانوا
الناس مع بعض الجيران ولا اهل والعوائل يا
ام فلان تدخل على طول من البيت لا لازم
اتصال تنسيق وما في بالبيوت
لكن من اول يوم فلان من اول بيت مثلا فلان
مثلا
رمضانيه لا تنقطع يعيشها عبد العزيز
ورفاقه وسط حاله من الحنين الى الماضي
ونفس الشيء
عنا صغار اللي هو علي بابا
افلام كرتون مدبلجه هذه لازم بعد الناظره
كنادي اروع بلادي كل المملكه نشوفه
الصالون
تقول
مؤخرا فاتت المزارع ملاذا للكثير من اهالي
عنيزه لقضائي ليالي شهر رمضان المبارك
والاستمتاع بالتقصير المعتدل
ايضا في ليالي رمضان يفضل الكثير من اهالي
عنيزه تناول السحور في الهواء الطلق
وتبادل القصائد والاشعار عبد الرحمن
العصيمي من مدينه عنيزه العربيه
قالت مصادر وحكوميه بان رئيس الوزراء
الشيخ احمد النواف يجتمع اليوم مع الوزراء
في قصر بيان لنقل توصيات القياده السياسيه
ومناقشه النهج الذي ستتبعه الحكومه في
المرحله المقبله وفقا لصحيفه القبس
الكويتيه ياتي هذا الاجتماع بعد لقاء
النواب يوم امس مع نائب الامير وولي العهد
الشيخ مشعل الاحمد كما سيعقد مجلس الامه
برئاسه مرزوق الغانم ولا جلساته يوم غد
الثلاثاء بعد عودته وفقا لحكم المحكمه
الدستوريه
كشفت النشره الرباعيه الاولى لوزاره
التجاره السعوديه عن تسجيل نمو في اصدار
السجلات التجاريه خلال الربع الاول من
العام الجاري كما بينت ارقام النشره المدن
والانشطه الاقتصاديه الاعلى اصدارا نتابع
الاول من 20
3 56 الف سجل تجاري جديد 31 منها تملكها
سيدات الرياض الاولى والاعلى بنسبه 19000
مكه الثانيه والشرقيه الثالثه قطاع الجمله
والتجزئه الاعلى بواحد وعشرين الفجل قطاع
التشييد جاء ثانيا بنحو عشره الاف سجل
اجمالي السجلات التجاريه في السعوديه بلغ
مليون و300,000 سجل 40% منها تعود لسيدات
من احياء الحجاز والشام الى خنادق الرصاص
والموت خلال الحرب العالميه الاولى يتناول
مسلسل سفر برلين ارتكبته الدوله العثمانيه
بحق اهل شبه الجزيره العربيه وتجنيد
الالزامي للشبان العرب دراما اجتماعيه
تاريخيه لا يغيب عنها الطابع الرومانسي
ضمن القصه اخر مشروع حضر له المخرج الراحل
حاتم علي قبيله وفاته وهو من
اخراج الليث حجو البطوله توزعت بين النجوم
من السعوديه وسوريا ولبنان والعالم العربي
المزيد في تقرير الدراما مع سهى الوعل
واعداد ايام القاسم
[موسيقى]
تعرفوا ايش يسمون دولتك في اوروبا الرجل
المريض
كل الحين قاعد انتظره يموت
الكل مجتمع يبغى يسقط دوله الاسلام بابنود
[موسيقى]
مرحبا تسريب دراما لملحمه مؤلمه بعد مئه
عام هذا هو مسلسل سفر ابرليك اللي كان
مفاجاه الموسم الدرامي رمضانى الضخمه عن
كارثه التهجير الجماعي القسري اللي طبقتها
الدوله العثمانيه عام
1915 تجاه الالاف من الرجال والنساء
والاطفال من سكان المدينه المنوره حدث
تاريخي كان من المهم جدا للدراما ان
تتناولوا يوما هذا حدث
له قيمه التاريخيه وايضا قيمته الانسانيه
ويعتبر اليوم وكانه جريمه حرب لانه تم
تهزيرها للمدينه حتى قيل في كثير من
المصادر التاريخيه انه لم يبقى الا 41 شخص
من اهالي المدينه
يقتلون المدينه المنوره تم تهجيرا بالكامل
الم ورفاق دراسه الجامعيه في اسطنبول
السوري يحيى اللبنانيين فايز وفريد حيث
يخوض الاصدقاء الاربعه رحله الوعي السياسي
والانتقال من اروقه التحصيل العلمي الى
جبهات القتال مع الجيش العثماني اولا في
معارك البلقان على الحدود الروسيه ومن ثم
التمرد على ظلم السلطنه العثمانيه ووحشيه
ممارساتها انا فعلا في اسطنبول يعني فعلا
حسن في اسطنبول الابنيه التفاصيل
الديكورات المحلات اللبس المترو العربيات
الحنطور التفاصيل التفاصيل التفاصيل جدا
كلها موجوده وكلها موضوعه بعنايه لدرجه
انه فعليا الواحد فينا بيصدقني اسطنبول
بالارز لما صورنا على حدود البلقان كان
كمان شي كتير حلو لانه عبد الرحمن مثلا
كثير كان بالنسبه له الثلج كثير كبير
وكثير كان الجو حلو هنيك وما حسينا حالنا
يعني انه افترقنا هلا كتير اشتقنا للسات
هون كمان بس مره كان كمان كانت مغامره
لقلنا انا وعبد الرحمن ويحيى الج
مهور
[موسيقى]
اذا كان مكتوب على اهل ذي البلاد انهم
يحاربون
الهم اولى في جهادهم ودمهم
اعلن قاده الائتلاف الحكومي في اسرائيل
وقاده المعارضه في تصريح مشترك ان هناك
تفاؤلا حذرا بشان المحادثات بينهما التي
جرت في منزل الرئيس الاسرائيلي التصريح
المشترك اكد على اتفاق الطرفين على ضروره
الوصول الى حل طويل الامد وتوضيح ان كل
الاطراف الاسرائيليه تدرك معنا عدم التوصل
الى اتفاق وطني واضافت تصريح المشترك ان
المحادثات ستستانف بعد عطله عيد الفصح
قرر الرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي او تاجيل
اقاله وزير الدفاع بسبب الوضع الامني في
البلاد فهذا مراسل العربيه ان نتنياهو لم
يقل جالنت رسميا ولم يسلمه رساله اقاله
خطيه موقعه بل ابلغه شفهيا
قال الرئيس الروماني ان حلف الشمال
الاطلسي النيتو يحتاج الى وجود اكبر في
البحر الاسود مشددا على ضروره ادراج قضايا
البحر الاسود في جميع القضايا ذات الصله
اقوم اصبح البحر الاسود ذا اهميه
استراتيجيه اكثر من اي وقت مضى لهذا السبب
نعتقد ان النيتو يحتاج الى وجود اكبر في
البحر الاسود وهذا يعني ادراج قضايا البحر
الاسود في جميع العمليات ذات الصله لتعزيز
امن المنطقه الاوروبيه والاطلسي
اكد التقرير امريكي ان رئيس مجلس النواب
كيفن ماكارتي سيلتقي رئيسه تايوان
في كاليفورنيا الاربعاء المقبل وكانت
الصين حذرت من عقد هذا الاجتماع باعتباره
خرقا لمبدا الصين الواحده والسياده وادان
التوقف رئيسه تايوان في الولايات المتحده
اثناء رحله تقوم بها الى امريكا الوسطى
قالت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه ماونينج ان السبب الرئيسي وراء
التوترات في شبه جزيره الكوريه هو
التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه بين كوريا
الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده واليابان
طالما اصرت الصين الحفاظ على السلام
والاستقرار في شبه جزيره الكوريه واخلاء
شبه الجزيره من الاسلحه النوويه وبناء
اليه السلام في شبه الجزيره وحل المشاكل
من خلال الحوار وتشاور وفي الوقت الحالي
لم يتم اجراء التدريبات العسكريه بين
ولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه بعد انتهت
التدريبات المشتركه بين الولايات المتحده
واليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه واحده تلو
الاخرى ولا تزال حامله الطائرات الامريكيه
التي تعمل بالطاقه النوويه تجوب شبه
الجزيره وهذا هو السبب الرئيسي وراء عدم
انحسار التوترات في شبه الجزيره
اعلنت الفلبين عن موقعي اربع قواعد عسكريه
اضافيه تستخدمها القوات الامريكيه احدها
بالقرب من بحر الصين الجنوبي واخروا
بالقرب من تايوان اقل مكتبه الاتصالات
الرئاسي في بين له ان المواقع الاربعه
تعتبر مناسبه وذات منفعه متبادله
افادت وسائل الاعلام الصوماليه بوقوع
انفجار استهدف قافله لقوات الاتحاد
الافريقي في العاصمه مقديشو اشارت
التقارير الى سماع دوي اطلاق نار عقب
للانفجار
ننتقل الى مشاهده هذه الصور المباشره
لانتشار افراد الشرطه امام مبنى محكمه في
منهات قبيله مثول الرئيس
الامريكي السابق
اذا هذه صور لانتشار امني امام مبنى محكمه
في منهات قبل ان يمثل الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالدز ترامب امام هذه المحكمه
ويبلغ فيها رسميا بتهم الموجهه اليه كان
الرئيس الامريكي الخامس والاربعين قد ندد
وحلفائه بالاتهامات الزائفه والمخزيه حسب
قولهم معتبرين انها من تدبير الديمقراطي
لتعطيل حملته
الرئاسيه طبعا يذكر بان هذه التهمه التي
ستوجه الى دونالد ترامب ستكون متعلقه
باموال دفعها الى ممثله اباحيه في وقت
سابق
قبل خمسين عاما كان موعد الافطار عند
العرب موحدا التفاصيل في تقويم عقد
الزعايك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انتم تدرون انه قبل خمسين سنه كان والناس
جميع يفطرون الساعه 12 بنفس التوقيت بما
يسمى بالتوقيت الغروبي او الساعه العربيه
وهي ساعه المتوائمه مع التكاليف الشرعيه
من راحه في ساعه الواحده فكانما قرب بدنه
فاليوم الشرعي يبدا من مغيب الشمس فمساء
الخميس نقول له ونسميه ليله الجمعه وليله
رمضان نبدا نصلي التراويح وليله العيد
نخرج زكاه الفطر ويبدا التكبير ومع تواصل
العالم في وسائل التواصل التقليديه
الراديو والتلفزيون انكمش هذا التوقيت
وتدخل علينا التوقيت الزوالي التي
نستخدمها الان فالساعه الغروبي تضبط
عقاربها مع غروب الشمس وساعه زوالي تضبط
عقاربها مع زوال الشمس عقارب الساعه مع
الساعه هدور الى منى ومالنا ما هي لنا
الادمي مخلوق يطغيها الغرور يبني امال
والموت يهدم ما بنى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والساعه الغروبي بين قوسين العربي واللي
اهلنا الاولين الله يرحمهم كانوا
يستخدمونه يتبع نظام الشمس الحقيقيه ليش
لان عقارب الساعه تضبط بشكل يومي على مغيب
الشمس والساعه الزوالي التي نستخدمها الان
تتبع نظام الشمس الخياليه والوقت انفس ما
عنيت بحفظه واراه اسهل ما عليك يضيع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ختام رابعه بابرز عناوينها
امن عام حلف الناتو يعتبر ان تقديم الصين
مساعدات عسكريه لروسيا سيكون خطا جسيما
عشيه محاكمته في منهات ترامب يؤكد انه
سيستعد منصب الرئاسه في الانتخابات
المقبله
مصادر كويتيه تكشف عن اجتماع لمجلس
الوزراء اليوم والبرلمان يعقد غدا اولى
جلسات بعد قرار الدستوريه
وزاره التجاره السعوديه تكشف عن تسجيل 65
الف سجل تجاري جديد خلال الربع الاول
نهايه رابعه شكرا لكرم ولطف المتابعه الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]